Oh you are hard to look at
like a testicle with teeth look like
Freddy Krueger face-fucked a
topographical map of Utah exactly you
are haunting look like an avocado had
sex with an older avocado thank you
hey youtubers is charlie so I wanted to
do a Deadpool QA just because everyone's
still going so crazy about the trailer
it's amazing the polarizing reaction
between what's going on with Fantastic
Four in what's going on with Deadpool
and I will be doing a fantastic for
video but not till tomorrow so here we
go let's talk about some tacos first
question godless nerd asks does anyone
know what's up with the two trailers are
they going to release a censored version
of the film no no there'll be one
version the film in theaters it'll be
r-rated Reyn Reynolds was just teasing
everyone when he said it was going to be
pg-13 that was supposedly some April
Fool's Day joke the reason for the
censored version of the trailer like the
two different versions there's the red
band just consider that like the normal
trailer but because of the content in it
because because of like the graphic
stuff they have in it they can only show
it during certain times of the day in
certain markets and in certain platforms
this is just in America but like it you
know if they want to show it to the
widest possible audience they just have
to make it less graphic so that's what
the censored version is for I know it
sounds weird it doesn't make sense movie
ratings don't make any kind of sense
next question Ahmed asks is Deadpool
immortal since he can heal instantly
well he's functionally immortal so yes
he's immortal but there's like an
asterisk appends on the way you
explained immortality apocalypse is
another example of an immortal mutant
but his ability is biological Deadpool
got his through the Weapon X program and
despite all that they can still be
killed like Wolverine could still lose
his healing factor they did a big
storyline in the comics called death of
Wolverine so when we say Deadpool is
immortal we say pretty much immortal in
order for someone to be like absolutely
immortal i would say they'd be on like
God level powers look even Galactus and
franklin richards can be killed and
there are two of the most powerful
beings in the multiverse next question
Gabriel asks will cable or Domino have a
cameo I don't think the cables in the
movie and nothing that I have heard
about the movie no spoilers nothing says
anything about cable being present
Easter eggs you know maybe there might
be some funny jokes about cable Domino I
do believe has a small part in the film
we've really only seen the main cast but
there are a ton of other people from the
comics in the film in like really small
ways so just keep your eyes peeled for
easter eggs and cameos domino being one
of those next question Brian asks so is
he supposed to be the
same movie Wade Wilson he was an x-men
origins wolverine but in an alternate
post Days of Future past time line so
you're saying like you know how has days
of future past affected the Wolverine
Origins Deadpool just assume that that
did not exist assume it didn't happen
that was one of the backdoor benefits of
Days of Future past it killed x-men 3
like the third x-men film that Bryan
Singer did not work on and wolverine
origins so if you want to get technical
just consider that Wayne Wilson an
alternate timeline this one is now the
main one consider the Deadpool movie to
be mainstream continuity with the x-men
films next question Lou Rick asks do you
think an x-force spin-off would be
possible yet they were actually there's
one in development they just I think
they put it on hold because they're
doing the Deadpool movie I think they're
still trying to work out an X 4 script I
think it's still in that stage of
development they have everything under
Marvel's X banner so of course they're
going to do x-force at some point in
Deadpool being a huge export character
in the comics it only makes sense that
they would try to bring those together
at some point that being said depending
on the success of Deadpool I think that
we won't see x-force for a little while
longer but they definitely want to make
that movie next question in sacks ops
asks i thought the deadpool is supposed
to break the fourth wall he did in the
teaser trailer why didn't he do it in
the main trailer yeah I think they
either hadn't finished the scenes from
the the rest of the movie that they
wanted to use in the trailer with him
breaking the fourth wall or they felt
like it just didn't work in the scenes
that they were going to include the
trailer already the main purpose of the
trailer is really to sell the film to
people who don't understand who Deadpool
is like who's dead pool why is he so
awesome why should I go see this movie
so having him break the fourth wall in
the trailer probably would have just
been confusing like if you didn't
understand that that's what Deadpool
already does I think they just wanted to
play it safe and not make it super
confusing for non comic book people next
question any asks do you think that will
ever see any spider-man and Deadpool
crossovers I was it not anytime soon I
think that there were people that would
love to do that at the studios but it
took Marvel forever to make that
arrangement with Sony most of the time
like these big studio crossovers just
depend on the success of individual
franchises like if Deadpool is super
successful on his own
just with the characters that fox owns
then they won't have any incentive to
try and go after Marvel or Sony
characters so pending years of
negotiations with like teams and teams
of lawyers behind the scenes don't plan
on any spider man at a Deadpool movie
but he could he could make like
spider-man jokes like in an offhanded
away like the way they did an ant-man
they talked about a dude crawling up
walls and that line was actually in the
ant-man movie before Marvel and Sony
made their arrangement so if Marvel can
get away with that then Deadpool could
probably it away with that too next
question Kenny it's asks is Ajax being
played by the initial Dario yet that is
the first Dario I actually was not a fan
of his if you don't watch Game of
Thrones it's just he played a character
on Game of Thrones that was later recast
but it had nothing to do with the way
they felt about him he just he joins
another project and there was a
scheduling conflict so they had to
recast the role he really didn't even
speak that much next question in kountze
waggle asks do you think if this film is
successful then Fox and Hugh Jackman
could do an r-rated cut of their next
Wolverine film like oh man okay you're
talking an old man Logan it's super
graphic comic book storyline I mean is
how hardcore no I think that any movie
that Hugh Jackman does is going to be
sold to the the widest audience possible
and they just they can't do that if it's
rated R I think it might be a little
more hardcore like like a hardware pg-13
but yeah there's just like some things
that you're probably never going to see
Hugh Jackman do on screen that being
said old man Logan is probably the
storyline they're going to go with but
it won't be like a literal adaptation
they'll just use the framework and some
of the themes from old man Logan in the
comics to do the story of the movie and
as for releasing like two different cuts
of the movie I mean even even though
that's an interesting thought no I don't
think they would want to dilute ticket
sales of like anyone cut of the film so
it'll be like one cut in theaters the
only time you see studios release
different cuts at the same time it's for
international releases like China for
instance has very very strict rules
about what kind of movies they'll allow
in the country and it's a billion-dollar
market so it's just like a giant cash
cow for studios so if the Chinese
government wants them to studios will
recut films in any way necessary to get
their film into China but that's like
the one exception next question
Sebastian asks what other than him
knowing he's in a comic makes him
amazing
to you you're saying like what's awesome
about Deadpool I would say most of all
he was self referential before it was
cool to do that like nowadays it's
really common to see people break the
fourth wall make really meta jokes about
things that are happening in the fandom
comment on the ridiculous nature of
narratives inside stories Deadpool was
one of the first big comic book
characters to do that in like a really
big overt way and beyond that on a small
level he's one of the like the most
supernatural characters in Marvel Comics
orkut comics in general and when I say
supernatural I'm not talking about his
powers I'm talking about the way the
narrative presents him there are certain
things the characters can't get away
with they understand that Deadpool
though is not bound by that his super
state in the narrative allows him to do
pretty much anything that you could
possibly imagine he was created as this
character that just doesn't give a crap
about anybody's agenda and therefore
became the character that would say the
unsayable things he's at the
personification of a meme so he's pure
comedy but at the same time he's
grounded in like crazy crazy violence
thank you so much everyone for so many
questions these are always a ton of fun
to do I just I feel like right now
Deadpool is so interesting to talk about
I could go all day let me know if any of
you signed up for Marvel unlimited to
read all like the Deadpool back issues
since you've seen the trailer I know a
lot of you guys already subscribe to
Marvel unlimited it's just it's just
like their bulk comics subscription
model where you can read a bunch of
their old stuff so in related news i
know i said i'm seeing fantastic for
tonight i'll do a non-spoilery review
first then i'll do an easter egg video
for the most part what I've been hearing
is is like the first two thirds of the
film is fine like completely fine
totally normal comic book movie totally
enjoyable it's like the last big act of
the fit like the last third that just
kind of falls apart a little bit I
haven't seen it yet so I'll try to
provide some more context whenever I
post my review video really I think the
worst complaint that I've heard about
the film is that it wastes some of the
actors talents like the actor that plays
dr. doom Toby Kebbell is a great actor
in edge I hear the film wastes a lot of
him but that's really true of a lot of
films on the flip side of that in the
Marvel Universe if you've watched
daredevil think about the way they
developed the kingpin character he was
as much a main character as daredevil
was like they almost shared the same
a screen time so we'll see even if the
movie is not great I'd still go see it i
still love seeing movies that are bad
but either way there's like a whole lot
of like behind-the-scenes drama with
fantastic for the actual making of the
movie that I'll try and talk about
during my review video it is completely
fascinating so while you guys wait for
that stuff to post you can click here to
watch the Deadpool red band trailer
again and you can click here to learn
all about vandal savages history in the
comics he's going to be coming onto the
flash season two legends of tomorrow and
arrow thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you